oh
[Music]
foreign
all right so
it's like you're going to find rokio
your your rokio is right here okay
thank you and you do want to go
you want to play the shoulder elbow
wrists off each other okay you can come
around and you go to rock your
okay but he
counters by coming around do you see
go back so let's let's go slow let's say
I'm trying to do rokio he counters by
coming around and dropping his elbow
underneath you're not gonna get broken
so you don't fight for rokio
you're in rokio he comes around and you
let rokio go and you're in Nico okay
so make sure
I I tend to think of it that way
I'm trying to rokio even though it's
Keyhole do I do I feel and sense rokio
being passed through I don't go to the
risk okay
boom around
boom okay
next thing
when he comes around go ahead
he's coming around you don't want to
crush him down here
you want to keep
you want to keep his kazushi going
so you're not trying to break his wrist
you're going to go in his body
you make him move past you
so watch for that I won't go fast but
I'll go smooth and you're gonna see
how I'm doing that
do not advise that UK to want to lay
down there
okay you're going to add tensions to the
wrist law
[Music]
I can move past you so you'll have this
opening
okay
and practice being his Center and out in
his wrist
there is I want to open your mind more
[Music]
to the rokio
okay
so again
as as he
counters the rokio he's saying drops his
elbow he's trying to drop the silver
he's like yeah he's he's who would put
themselves in Nico that's the strategy
of wristwatch I don't chase wrist lock I
don't chase risks
I don't chase the risk the dude puts
himself in the technique thank you do
you understand that okay so
and you're here
on the EQ for example it's as he's he's
trying to get up that post he's trying
to get up where is he going broke you
see
it's not I would never take someone to
equal and then decide to go rokio okay
likewise I'm not gonna go from here and
to there you see that that that Gap to
there that's where you're gonna lose the
guy right because I don't I'm not
controlling his elbow
you see I have this here I have his
elbow okay and now he has to do
something with it oh he does do
something with it
and what I use this technique for
is to get him out from in front of me
you see he's in front of me right so I'm
gonna make him go fight me
again it's because you're in his Center
so when I'm when I'm here like this uh
I'm going to be
okay
you can take one hand you can take your
hand off you you can take your body off
and you still
I'm moving him
by his Center
all that
so that you understand that it's an
energetic manipulation and not a
skeletal manipulation because sometimes
you're doing weird things to get him to
move that way well you took the you took
the lock off okay so
I hear I could drop his forearm down you
see and make him go that way
but I don't have to drop his forearm
down
so don't do something
so mechanical that is to the detriment
of the actual lock that you're trying to
use for him to fall into
okay do you guys got that so
if you pay attention I do it a little
different every single time because the
the the surface level the mechanical
level is not important that that's not
important
okay so don't don't try to find some
some way here you are uh he does the
counter feel his body boom and move his
body
[Music]
okay try it again